alright guys some of you oh gee the
score you sports fans might remember we
did a top-10 wallbangs video way back in
2017 and while that list is good a lot
has changed since then new insane wall
banks have emerged and frankly we've
kind of changed our minds a little bit
on some of the classics so here is the
new updated dare I say buffed list of
the top 10 wall bangs in csgo starting
our list off is a shot that in the hands
of simple looks almost well simple
[Laughter]
absolutely made me sound like a gorilla
now simple has made so many ridiculous
plays over the years that we've almost
become desensitized to them and this
shot is no different it looks like he's
doing enough does manage to force the
straw player away debris smack 10
connect simple I swear if you do
anything ridiculous now I am going to
[Laughter]
absolutely not you made me sound like a
gorilla facing off against two strollers
at IEM katowice 2020 simple tries to
retake a sight on dust2
and prevent the plant in the flashiest
way possible after all these years
simple still amazes and here's that the
jumping shot of course wallbang denying
the plan that says it all say okay well
today's not my day yeah taking the
number 9 spot on our list is Henny who
lit up banana with the nastiest of
wallbangs
at this Star Series season 3 and a
qualifier match against misfits oh Jesus
dude what is that what is that Wow
now shooting someone through the banana
wall on Inferno isn't exactly rare but
flicking to a head shot through the wall
wow flashed well that's the kind of play
that belongs on this list that's twice
now he shot somebody in the face through
that wall hit it on T side and now he
did it on CT
what the hell any
coming in at number eight is mr.
30-degree window himself
Drakken what was that hurry Drakken
is this a simulation hurry now dragon is
known for hitting wild flicks with his
trusty op sure but this shot in
particular showcases just how impressive
those shots can be can I do this
it's about goes down knows that's the
seat seat Oh gets him through the wall
Drake an absolutely perfect why is that
coming out of the young sweet takes both
of them through the wall playing against
red reserve during Dreamhack open
Valencia tracking completely decimated
the Swedish defense and let's just point
out that both of those wall bangs were
in the 30 degree window and then he's
like okay I'm not done yet relaxing his
that his spidey sense is tingling take
you number seven spot on our list is one
hell of a call-out from Kenny s you
don't like to see that there are a few
spots in cs:go where you'll shoot
through the wall to warn your opponents
not to cross you but Kenny Kenny doesn't
give warnings squeaky do all mall itself
to still to push the start you don't
like to see that all it took was one
unfortunate sound cue from somebody in
squeaky for Kenny to absolutely delete
him through the wall effortlessly no
warnings no mercy
that doesn't happen ever by the way that
is not a normal thing that occurs one
bullet fired off randomly towards a
squeaky door at our number six spot is
an oldie but a goodie courtesy of wallet
I mean fallin fallin is a player who can
surgically dismantle any team through
any surface and this shot is a prime
example of his incredible skill at the
Cologne 2015 major fallin is in a 1v3
and well we don't really need to tell
you at
next they're gonna be able to at the
bomb plant and happy even waiting for
the push in fallen gets the spray shot
anyway that I K well but that I don't
even know it was you just watched a
noscope through the wall and through the
smoke it seemed like fallen did
everything he could to make that shot
impossible then hit it anyway wall and
strikes again simply hitting someone
through a wall alone
is it enough to make this list you have
to make it look good and that's exactly
what get right did to snag the number
five spot what is that reaction yeah
right see nuke has often been get rights
playground and at the ESO pro league
season four semi-finals he showed
sk-gaming exactly why that is SK 9 to 13
this crowd wants anything to cheer for
but it's been all ni P in the second
half pissed around one by SK and they
haven't gotten a single round after that
yeah right oh what is that reaction yeah
right you can run you can hide but get
right will always find you
he just spots like that he just spots
the pixel out of the corner of his eye
or corner of his screen and what what a
snap coming in at number four is the
mustache twirling Fragger himself
gratis faction wanna start to the game
for cratis faction I haven't seen a shot
like that at some time caught in a
sticky situation during IEM Beijing 2019
against vitality gratis faction was able
to showcase not only his mechanical
prowess but also his map knowledge with
this insane flick this is where my tena
bean to remind themselves there's no
bump on yet all the pressure of the time
of right now is 100 saves and
faction he's trolling me taking down
shots as well and a hundred thieves
stealing the round trust us on this one
guys
Shox had absolutely no idea what hit him
that's what a two on for recovery
vitality had everything on the defense
this is this is incredible stuff at the
number three spot is a wall bank so
incredible valve had to take it out of
the game
way back in 2017 the French pro body
figured out that if you shot through a
specific wall on cash one minute and 49
seconds into the round you were
extremely likely to get a kill yeah of
course yeah it was done that really just
hit that was from Shaun have we got the
replay here it is in all his glory is
insane boom a few moments later 10 -
like you said difficult
bodies trying it again oh this I like
this we're seeing it from the CT POV
gonna see what's going through his mind
before God the body bang as people
started calling it was a deadly tool and
valve quickly patched it out of the game
but body ensured his signature shot was
immortalized forever in his krakow major
sticker once in every csgo players life
they hit a truly unbelievable shot and
for our runner-up spot ilish shows us
that pros are no different surprise what
did god names going on even he just like
shook his hat it is like what have I
just done players love to shoot at walls
with specific timings hoping that they
hit something and most of the time they
don't and we forget about it but
sometimes you win the lottery and you're
popping off for the rest of the game
just challenging over it banana or
actually just push for the smoke no
gonna find anyone up there
[Music]
Wow even who surprised what did God
names going on even he just like shook
his hat it is like what have I just
Dodman with this play Ali showed us that
even the best of them can hit shots that
they can't believe in cs:go hitting one
wall banging around is definitely
impressive hitting tune around
improbable hitting three come on that's
downright impossible but if anyone can
make the impossible possible it's nifty
if the pretty close see the kill pop up
in the feed but he will have another
crack at a shot and this time he does to
live Oh nifty is disgusting and look
where the bombs drop now as well he
knows that Nifty's up in heaven and
therefore his rotation to a could be cut
off if he can scamper past and the a
site may very well be right for the
taking a small crack that he can see in
somebody's landed the Scout shot my
colleague I'm done
this honestly might look like he's
cheating because only a god could pull
this off and nifty apparently is that
god thing is that shot by itself is
disgusting but you have to keep into
consideration he lands a wall buying for
his second kill as well to drop the bomb
in the first place dad
this guy has game sense like no other
that is absolutely disgusting okay guys
that was it for the top ten wall bangs
in csgo
let us know in the comments section what
old video you want us to revisit next
and if you haven't already subscribed to
the YouTube channel and head on over to
twitch.tv slash the score esports and
give us a follow it won't regret it
here's a weird piece of my collection in
the back of my set this old musty no
cover book I got in Cuba I got it from a
guy who was selling a bunch of old
vintage books in a square in Havana in
Cuba and I talked to the guy because
he's
okay English and he was actually saying
that he was a lawyer in Cuba he was a
professional and he got paid so little
and being a lawyer in Cuba was so
difficult he was a young guy he was
about my age at the time that he on the
weekends and probably other times too
had to stand in a square and sell old
books and I thought that was really
eye-opening so I've always kept this
this old musty horror book a because if
you're gonna read a book of horror short
stories it should look like this right
it's kind of like a creepy looking book
but be just to remind me of how lucky we
all are where we live